I have already laid them to show that
it's not enough it's not enough just to
find cool second derivative is zero
right it's not enough um you have to say
well just be careful right now I'm going
to give you the big example and as soon
as I as soon as I write it on the board
in some second in some senses
you'd be like oh of course but this is
it's important that you get in your cat
it you know category your head for why
that word may is there okay so put it up
y equals x it's lovely to be able to
take a really simple example and see
what's going on here y equals x to the
four is very easy to differentiate right
I can find the first derivative and the
second derivative almost without
thinking first derivative X cubed second
derivative you just go again and you get
12x squared now immediately and I'm not
going to do this formally we can just do
this on the son you can see it right
immediately you can see all right where
are you going to get stationary points
at the origin right so this implies
there's a stationary point at zero zero
and that's the only solution to pursue
to be easier but when you look at the
second derivative right this clearly
spot where the second derivative is zero
right I can say the second derivative is
zero at the same point right at zero
zero okay but what does this look like
how do we usually like we've drawn y
equals x to the fourth before what is
this thing look like Miss drawing yeah
yeah you've got an IQ right it's um it's
a parabola that's well it's a bit flat
at the bottom now we've said oh it's a
bit flat it's a bit flat now we have do
we have languages it's not just a bit
flat
it is flat it's flat in a way that a
normal problem is not that's why when we
draw it you should draw us something
like that okay at that point right there
the origin right so this is my quick and
dirty y equals x to the 4
right there is actually no concavity
right it's not like those little Morgan
station points on the story before right
at every point if you have a parabola
but maths will tell you the numbers will
tell you that everywhere in this domain
I'm concave up okay well when you go
ahead and you have a look at this guy
right you have to think about the
numbers here it's an even function
that's an even function it's concave up
almost everywhere almost everywhere
right concave up also uh but at the
origin there is no concavity at x equals
0 the second derivative is zero now have
a look at my errors have a look at my
concavity my redcon caviar is right is
there a change in concavity clearly not
it's concave up on the left it's concave
up on the right there is no point of
inflection here okay so I would say
there is no point of inflection as
there's no change in the sign of the
cavity right and I can draw the table
that is to demonstrate that
in fact just because it's so should
really save one this is meant to be like
a kind of seminal example for us let's
just quickly draw this label right so
you need I always buy the way you're
trying to do this in a quick way you
should have the table I think you should
have lines I think you can get away
without gluing them because you have to
draw so many of these things I always go
like this half half and then have it
twice to get quarters right because then
you get exactly the right lines that you
need it's not really that hard shouldn't
take the volunteer joystick so you've
got your exercising you get a test
you're going to test I've got everything
in terms of why it's not in terms of F's
right I know it's zero that's where
interesting things happen what happen to
the left and to the right well there is
there's my first second review sorry so
it's good well and then it's gonna be 12
no changing the sign in this particular
example yes you could so what RAF is
talking about is I could say from this
line I would guess I would say it but d
squared Y on the x squared is greater
than or equal to 0-4 for all values of X
therefore can't possibly have a change
change in sign because it'll never ever
ever go negative that's a possibility
but it's not a very I I'm not I'm not
going to teach you that as a as an
approach because but this is pretty much
the only example that works there were
plenty of functions where it's like now
a change of sign all the time but at
this particular point I'm just
interested in this particular point it
doesn't change sign there
so therefore
yes so well kind of so X to the six you
can see I could do this exact same
process again right and it's going to
look like this but but steep up except
right there it's still going to have
well you know just really quickly if you
want X to the six then when you
differentiate what you'll get six x to
the 5 we need a different shape again
you'll get right so everything that is
over this sorry for everything that's on
this fall will have a second derivative
being zero at that point and you have
their point of instruction okay because
it's an even function so it's going to
go down and it's gonna fall right so in
fact it's a bit of